so Victor come you buy the best year to
argue that the one we met connects us
all is actually worthless so if you're
going to start with introductions to why
we left yeah what we're doing now so my
name is Dan I'm the co-founder of thick
full and I left because there's actually
not that much risk in didn't even think
about it
you're always welcome to go back it's
been around for a couple engineers will
probably be there for another few
Moore's we need it and I figured there
was a chance that I could actually find
something that I love doing and learn a
lot anytime
Finley hey guys a typical on and I
actually I should let the help because I
always knew that the real solution for
building commercial robotics wasn't
gonna come from academia and when I was
offered the deal Belgium I kind of
thought it's like a one-of-a-kind
opportunity to go out and like actually
start working on like what I've always
wanted to what I've always wanted to
know my name is Darren
ochio gets up spending a lot of time
involved in research actually and I more
interested in sort of the intersection
of biology and translational science of
how do we actually commercialize a lot
of the interesting things that's a
little bit more like what I've been
working with small team of three
different groups of backgrounds
obsession their combination of
interesting tough technology animation
processing machine learning applied to
take patient patient issues biopsies to
enhance the quality of treatments
colleges provide as well as high quality
recognizes so first question goes to you
I'm wondering if the Yale network still
proved useful even though you don't have
been a great yeah good question so the
simple answer is absolutely I
nobody has has ever not wanted to talk
to me because I did not graduate and
I've been I've been surprised by a
couple of things one is how many haley's
there are in the world
and I'm not sure if it's just because
they're very over-represented in the
sorts of people I tend to meet but just
literally probably every one to two
weeks I run into somebody and a
completely unexpected time that turns
out to be at Yale he just last week I
was I was is in a partner meeting with
this big debt fun about buying loads on
our marketplace and it turns out one of
the partners there was yellow lung
itself and then add sort of second thing
I've been surprised by is how sticky the
question of which residential college he
went to is across
years of generation so you know where
this big heart beating and everybody
just stops to listen to us have you know
the kind of stupid conversation I know
it was a ventricular you in it go back
before any time but yes implants is
absolutely and David you actually
decided to go back to school I'm
wondering why and what he most
accomplished for sure yeah I think I
kind of had a really long adventures
throughout like my entire academic
career the interesting thing was when I
was at Yale I was even though entirely
restricted Eurovision replies I never
studied anything that was that all
relevant to that I was a political
science major and a math major and
basically like how would how about my
work was like when I was younger I
didn't we can't see your science website
would be a tizzy well I got a
certificate to my local state college I
did a lot of research on the side I like
work that I wrote a lot for a while and
it's like I hadn't had all of all that
experience that was not a huge risk to
to to the minimum back I knew that I
wasn't actually coming back but I'll put
a large part of why I came back with Lee
because I'm very good working on tech
for so long I kind of suck nails like
really to really like to decorate some
plaque my life experiences like I
started out in directed studies when I
started with school there and went back
to my life school it was in large part
because I saw I was like one of those
one of the last remaining opportunities
that I actually go back and spend a lot
of time with with a bunch of people were
motivated like like different things
that may not always have been
those those pretty nose pretty greedy
and then the timing also worked out
really well for me as well because like
both ever was in this last year is grad
program
okay Darren do you think you missed
anything by not going back to school um
I think there's some things that I
really think yeah some people appreciate
it
a lot of these are very conservative
people obviously that's her
I think it's this combination it's not
just the density people boss impediment
the decorator has something that they
don't especially in Silicon Valley the
men I don't really view this as kind of
a ecologist your qualitative degrees
energy you see it's more like what is
the best thing so for a while actually
while supposed in Belgium I saw myself
becoming one more research I went again
some of the workers they became much
much more basic science and less less
translational and so it kind of thought
to myself maybe I should go back maybe
actually toxic what's the standard of
collaborating with a PhD you can then I
was like you know this is really why I
guess West was twenty year olds is one
that tasted existential crisis I'd like
I this is a big decision
I'm gonna take a quick trip lot to
Europe did like three weeks backpacking
trip came back and realize that I still
want to play around cyber science so
it's hard for gonna say sir this is a
really unique opportunity learn
different things that
could be useful so a question we often
get asks usually with a little bit of
worry and the person's voice is this
they're actually any value to the degree
at all for what we're doing Paul it's
run away so I guess my first thought on
that question is it might just be a sort
of eccentricity of our time but there's
this strange fascination I think
especially in Silicon Valley with people
who have dropped out and I think it's
because of a logical fallacy that goes
something like this
I heard of a person called Mark
Zuckerberg I know he dropped out of
college I know he made a lot of money
I hear you dropped out of college that
must mean you're gonna make a lot of
money like mark sorry and and so it you
know surprisingly I've actually found
that I think people tend to be more
positively inclined towards listening to
what I'm saying when I tell them that
I've dropped out which is kind of weird
because that's not a reason to listen
more to me i but I think my college
experience was certainly very valuable I
don't think I could be where I am today
I did not spend two years at Yale or in
college and for me and most of the
benefit came in in the social
development that I made while I was
there anything when I was just out of
high school you know didn't have a lot
of great social skills I certainly
didn't have the kind of emotional
maturity that that would be needed to do
anything independently and I think I
grew a lot personally while I was at
Yale and if I just didn't go to college
I think I would be screwed David you're
the only one who's with both in Silicon
Valley and in working on the startup can
you tell us about how the Yale community
is and is it a viable place to work on a
start-up your Haven is absolutely the
best place to be when you have a large
set of technical goals they need to
achieve in a very short time without a
lot of distractions and
like a huge huge Pro are essentially
we're building were building like a
general system everybody could use video
content and like the powered already
having many things on market side of
that most of the biggest that wasn't
whether or not we be able to to actually
deliver this product and as a result
what we really needed to do was for my
tech team to just focus on that was
absolutely and I think a really I think
it's a great place to be when you're
starting out building your company
especially because like why do I really
content it helps a lot of women using
you do a lot of relevant people in the
space like him holding you along the way
during the early stages and I think
that's really and another question we
often get is whether we could have done
what we did if we'd stayed in school and
maybe would have been two years too late
or maybe it wouldn't but that I think
you would be doing what you are if you
had said I don't think one of the
interesting things about the fellowship
that's really unique is that it really
gets puts you in a place crafted think
critically in an unstructured
environment right I feel like a lot
going to you I was like sky goes very
much off on that track of him work hard
in high school work out in college you
know get good job on this finance
management get stuck on a certain
default route and I think there's this I
could actually see this myself part of
the motivation I saw myself going down
that track without really thinking about
my parents that why is that care about
and so for part of me the real value of
the function is just spending this
unstructured time thinking about
whatever they're about and I start
sailing about stated you know gone down
that structure ground
it's just because it's it's just been
such a different amazing about you have
some more space and resources without
any sort of structure at all
dan what about you we've been talking a
lot and you're sort of in the same
position the one may be provocative
thought that I've sort of encountered is
I'm a question of whether people will
hold against you that you don't agree
about in a lot of ways once people know
that you got in they actually don't
really care what he did afterwards and
the cynical way to read that is actually
the admissions department is the
majority of the value of the love of the
system and that after that you know 99%
of people graduate so whether you can
stuck around and got the piece of paper
or not people don't really confer any
value on that experience it is
definitely a cynical way to read it but
in the two years that I was in college I
learned a lot and then immaterial not in
college I also learned a lot so it's not
really clear to me if that's if that's
unfavorable and I think just trying to
get us back on schedule so are there any
any questions from the audience
sure I think that's fair
the only thing I'd say is it's it's not
fair to read that what we're doing is
not educational in that you know the
next 25 years when I could do anything
educational I think most of us believed
they were what we've learned a ton in
the last few years and looking ahead to
the next twenty there will probably be
periods of our lives when we'll focus
full-time on education but that may not
happen at an institution that world is
changing and the the university system
is like fundamentally going through a
massive change right now it feels gotta
be fine we're still going to get the
best kids in the in the country there's
so many at the same number but if you
look at the vast majority of
universities they're really struggling
right now and that's only gonna get
worse over the next few years so how
people get educated is fundamentally
going to be different over the next few
decades I would just add that I don't
think any of us and I don't miss Peters
certainly but I think none of us here
believe that I you know everybody should
drop out or nobody should go to college
at all I think in fact we would probably
say the majority of people should spend
four years at college and I think you
know we all benefited from our time
there and just one thing that that's
sort of probably the four of us all
feels that we preferred learning sort of
in a very self driven environment much
more so than many other people and so we
feel particularly sort of suited to the
path that we took
I think I'll let somebody else take this
thing and have the question but I wanted
to address some of stuff you pointed out
at the beginning I think that like it's
it's really important for us not to do
any cargo cult thing when it comes to
entrepreneurship we say the word
entrepreneurship it being so many
different things and I think especially
in the current environment we place a
lot of emphasis on the notion of
entrepreneurship by itself whereas I'm
personally convinced that it doesn't
mean anything to be an entrepreneur
unless you personally are very highly
invested in a particular area that you
know that you wanted if you want to do
things in and I think that like when we
talk about entrepreneurship they should
really be much more grounded based on
like what people are pursuing as an
independent opportunity and that
entrepreneurship it smells like a
subject or like a career is is an
interesting definition they don't
necessarily totally agree with as well
so all that somebody else take like that
the second half of that question is
whether or not yes necessarily different
the if you look at the numbers he's
basically right they you know it was an
amazing financial aid policy and so due
to its peer schools and it's doing a
great job but it's eighteen years too
late the entire school system before
that is failing a massive percentage of
the students in our in our country you
know a lot of our peers are doing great
things for Teach for America or for
other schools and trying to work on that
problem but it's much more systemic than
that I think you know it's frankly too
late to solve that problem and no matter
what they do short of changing they the
school system and I think it's a great
stop there but even that's very small
the problem just runs much deeper and
it's that's too late in the life cycle
for them so ever they have a deep impact
so I guess the big question is whether
while we're you know I thought that the
culture really supported
entrepreneurship what kind of the Bible
is I'd say like I know this sort of
correlation it would pay that is
technologies
what would this is what about
entrepreneurship really mean is it
teaching you know make a business model
and teaching you how to quiet users or
is it something that's more kind of
deeply rooted about kind of fostering
interesting you know some doing that
care about that can actually change and
I think it's the latter than the else
very much getting supporting that kind
of creating students that interesting
that they care about that care about
things that matter and thinking about
sort of way of ways of moving on that
status quo so in that sense I think very
much Don VLDL be supportive